geht es hier weiter dann wird es
spannend für die Grünen denn dann stehen
rard und nupur zur Wiederwahl und nach
den vielen schlechten Wahlergebnissen
wir haben es auch gerade noch mal in
einem Redebeitrag gehört ist die Frage
wie gut werden die Wahlergebnissen der
Parteichefs aber jetzt geht es hier bei
phöniix weiter mit einem Blick auf den
Haushaltsstreit die Phönix Runde
übernimmt und das macht Alexander
kellerler Olaf der schweigerert der
Christian der staatstragende dieses
regierungstrio hat es wahrlich in sich
und soll die sogenannten multiblen
Krisen managen die von außen die von
innen und besonders die Suppe auslöffeln
die das Bundesverfassungsgericht
eingebrockt hat Wunschzettel zu Hauf
aber plötzlich kein Geld mehr in der
Kasse und der Weihnachtsmann kann auch
nicht helfen Milliardenloch wackelt die
Ampel jetzt in der
phönixrunde
[Musik]
phönixrunde achte es als meine Aufgabe
jetzt reinen Tisch zu machen wir können
erst dann wieder über das Jahr 2024 und
die nächsten Jahre sprechen wenn wir
einen rechtssicheren einen
verfassungsrechtlich gesicherten Zustand
haben und dazu wird es in der nächsten
Woche diesen Entwurf eines
Nachtragshaushaltes 2 23 geben also
erneutes Aussetzen der Schuldenbremse
diesem Jahr soll das heißen geht auch
gar nicht anders sonst gibt es nämlich
den nächsten Blitzeinschlag aus
Karlsruhe und damit herzlich Willkommen
bei uns meine Gäste Anna Liemann ist bei
uns Leiterin des parlamentsbüro der
Tageszeitung Tatz an die Höning leidet
die Wirtschaftsredaktion der Rheinischen
Post Frank a Meer ist Schweizer
Publizist in Deutschland und schreibt
unter anderem für das Magazin zizaro und
Michael Bröker ist Chefredakteur des
Medienunternehmens
Frau lmann sie haben die
Schuldenbremse als das eigentliche
Problem beschrieben und eine Reform oder
sogar die Abschaffung gefordert jetzt
wird diese Schuldenbremse auch wenn sich
der Bundesfinanzminister nicht getraut
hat den seinen zu sagen dass es das
Aussetzen ist sie wird ausgesetzt
verschafft jetzt den Bundeshaushalt fürs
ablaufende Jahr noch etwas
Luft aber eine richtige Abschaffung oder
eine Reform dafür fehlen in Deutschland
schlicht und ergreifend politische
Mehrheiten ja die Mehrheiten fehlen
zurzeit man braucht dafür eine zwei
Drittel Mehrheit im Bundestag damit man
das Grundgesetz entsprechend ändern kann
aber ich bin mir sicher die Diskussion
um eine Reform der Schuldenbremse die
beginnt genau jetzt
Brücker plötzlich klaffen ja Milliarden
Löcher in der Staatskasse wo liegt denn
die Lösung des ganzen dass man bestimmte
Ambitionen aufgibt oder verlangsamt aus
dem Klimaschutz Energiewende
Modernisierung der Infrastruktur oder
muss man sich einfach neue
Einnahmequellen erschließen ja bisher
gab's ja gar keine Ambition bei der
Ampel es gab ja nicht ein einziges Feld
in den letzten Jahren wo die Ampel mal
Prioritäten so gesetzt hat dass
vielleicht Ausgaben nicht getätigt
wurden darüber wird leider gar nicht
geredet also wenn frau Lehmann sich
darüber freut dass jetzt die Debatte
über die Schuldenbremse beginnt dann
freue ich mich darüber dass jetzt die
Debatte über sinnlose ineffektive
Ausgaben bei einem
Staatshaushalt der eine Billion Euro
Steuereinnahmen hat und jeden 10 €o ins
Bürgergeld gibt also es g so viele
Beispiele über die man jetzt mal reden
könnte beides muss jetzt auf den Tisch
man kann über die Schuldenbremse reden
man muss aber auch mal darüber reden wo
der Staat sich eigentlich in den letzten
Jahren wirklich verfranzt hat
finanzpolitisch Frau Höning also jetzt
wird die Schuldenbremse noch mal
ausgesetzt das geschieht technisch mit
einem sogenannten Nachtragshaushalt fürs
laufende Jahr damit will man verhindern
dass man über die Schuldenbremse weit
hinausgeht man muss ja irgendwie 45
Milliarden Euro verfassungskonform noch
unterbringen die sind alle schon
ausgegeben ist das eine gute Idee jetzt
von Christian Lindner und der Ampel zu
sagen trotz alle anderen Ankündigungen
wir müssen Sie einfach noch mal
aussetzen die schultenbremse im vorhinn
wäre das gar kein Problem gewesen für
das Jahr jetzt 2023 die Notlage zu
erklären angesichts von Energiekrise und
ukrainekrise das jetzt im Nachhinein zu
machen wo das Jahr fast rum ist zu sagen
ach übrigens wir hatten da im Januar ja
eine Notlage das glaube ich fliegt der
Ampel erneut um die Ohren das wird
wieder in Karlsruhe landen und dann wird
man sehen wie die dort entscheiden
eigentlich hat der Staat Geld genug er
müsste es nur sinnvoll ausgeben dann
wäre auch genug Geld da ich glaube das
wird nicht funktionieren mit diesem
Nachtragshaushalt aber es ist der
einzige Weg wie die Ampel jetzt da aus
dem Schlamassel akut kommt also damit es
nicht noch mal eine Klatsche aus
Karlsruhe gibt nach dem Mutter das ist
auch nicht verfassungskonform eine
Notoperation sozusagen Herr Meer sie
haben in unserer Sendung schon häufiger
gesagt sich als bekennenden Liberalen
bezeichnet auch bedauert dass es so
wenige in Deutschland gibt früen da ja
vielleicht auch ein eher einsames Dasein
was würden Sie tun wenn Sie an der
Stelle von Christian Lindner weren jetzt
in dieser Situation das ist jetzt aber
ganz eine schwierige Frage wenn er
aussteigt hat der die zwei am Rücken und
wenn er drin bleibt letztlich vielleicht
auch die Problematik sie haben es
angetönt Herr Böcker die Problematik ist
dass dieser Staat sich
überfordert ganz massiv überfordert das
geht daraus hervor dass zwei Parteien
die dazu neigen den Staat zu überfordern
nämlich die Sozialdemokraten und die
Grünen wobei die Grünen D daß noch
akzentuiert da kommt alles über den
Staat die sind dort drin die große
Mehrheit
und Christian Lindner vertritt eine
kleine Minderheit die sich arrangieren
muss regiert halt mit und hängt mit ja
er geh geht mit und hängt mit aber die
Liberalen sind zu schwach also würden
auch Neuwahlen würden Liberalen nicht
eine Kraft geben wo sie sich dann mit
jemandem anderen zusammentun könnten um
wirklich ihre Vorstellung von einem
Staat der sich in Grenzen hält zu
verwirklichen ich glaube da sehen sie
die Liberalen bisschen zu idealistisch
es ist ja jetzt nicht so dass es die
Hüter der freien Marktwirtschaft sind
auch auf das Konto der Liberalen gehen
sehr viele Subventionen Steuerbefreiung
beim Kerosin das unsinnige Tempolimit
Pendlerpauschale das wären ja auch alles
Sachen die man im Zuge der überflüssigen
Ausgaben abschaten Kön K mich jetzt
nicht davon überzeugen dass die
Liberalen gleich sind wie die Grünen und
die Sozialdemokraten sie sind letztlich
wenn gleich in deutscher bürokratischer
Weise sind sie
liberal ja WIS ich komme aus dem Land
mit Freisinnigen und das der tolle
Begriff und solche freisinnige habt ihr
leider nicht
1848 ging das schief bei uns
funktioniert es also das ist ganz klar
das sind nicht freisinnig in dem Sinn
aber immerhin repräsentieren sie eine
Kraft die nicht total auf den Staat
setzt die aber richtigerweise alle
suchen ihre Lobbytätigkeit das gehört
zum politischen Geschäft aber
grundsätzlich sind sie anders gut wir
haben jetzt im Moment eine
Haushaltssperre die vom finanz Minium
auch eingezogen worden ist jetzt dürfen
nur die dringend notwendigen Ausgaben
getätigt werden die entweder schon
genehmigt sind oder eben die wie die
Zuschüsse zuur Rentenversicherung
Kindergeld und auch Teile der
Verteidigungsausgaben notwendig sind die
unterliegen dieser haushalssperre nicht
gesperrt ist jetzt der Klima und
transformationsfond da sind 60
Milliarden ein bisschen mehr sogar noch
drin ist nicht alles weg da gibt es den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond insgesamt
200 Milliarden waren da zumindestens
drin den wenn das jetzt alles gesperrt
ist erinnert so ein bisschen an den
shutown in den USA ist das vergleichbar
oder sind bei uns die rechtlichen
Möglichkeiten
andere dass zumindestens Geld fließt
dort wo es fließen muss damit Staat und
Gesellschaft funktionieren nee das ist
nicht vergleichbar würde ich sagen also
dann wenn es jetzt nicht gelingt einen
Haushalt ein verfassungskonform Haushalt
für 2024 aufzustellen dann gilt erstmal
der Haushalt weiter also dann sind wir
in der vorläufigen Haushaltsplanung oder
Haushaltsführung und das bedeutet alle
Ausgaben wie sie bisher etatisiert Waren
werden auch getätigt aber neue Ausgaben
werden eben nicht mehr getätigt z.B wenn
wir über 8 Milliarden zusätzliche
Ukraine Hilfen für die Ukraine reden
dann stüte das jetzt z oder steht jetzt
zur Dispos Disposition das gleiche gilt
natürlich auch für die
versprochenen Investition z.B zur oder
oder Subvention zur Ansiedlung von
Chipfabriken etc aber ich wollte noch
mal was sagen zu Ihnen Herr weil sie
sagen
die Grünen und die SPD die neigen
historisch zu einer Überforderung des
Staates genau das was sie jetzt
Überforderung nennen nennen andere den
Wohlfahrtsstaat und es ist noch nicht
mal zwei Jahre her da waren wir in der
coronakrise da riefen alle nach genau
diesem Staat selbst die FDP und sagten
wir brauchen jetzt Hilfen um die
Wirtschaft zu stützen und das hat ja
auch sehr
erfolgreich geklappt ich meine das hat
ja auch Deutschland ist eben nicht in
die Rezession gerutscht wie alle
geglaubt haben und auch die
Arbeitslosigkeit ist nicht so in die
Höhe geschossen wie alle befürchtet
hatten aber wissen Sie das ist die
Schweiz genau gleich abgelaufen aber wir
haben weniger diese
staatsfetischismus sie können die
coronakrise das war ja genau der Trick
wenn man so wenn es bös sagt die
umwitmung quasi der
coronasituation auf die Klimapolitik vor
allem um das ging es ja wie
implementieren wir diesen ganze riesige
Anforderungskatalog zu einem
klimaneutralen Land möglichst kurz Zeit
zu zu machen also zu zwingen quasi aber
der tpieler der das gemacht hat war
Christian Lindner er hat diesen diese
Umwidmung vollzogen ja es war eine
schlaumeerei es ist ganz klar
taspiel schla
taspiel
die den gleichen Effekt also da ist
tatsächlich mit einer unglaublich
raffinierten Gestaltung was passiert da
hat man etwas umgewidmet was jetzt das
Bundesverfassungsgericht unterbunden hat
ansonsten hätte ja quasi die Politik vor
allen die Regierenden ja eine Art
kartblanche gehabt mit Steuergeldern bzw
Schulden machen auch so umzugehen wer
ist eigentlich wirklich der
Verantwortliche für dieses disaster
jetzt war das wirklich nur die Ampel
oder liegt das schon länger zurück wer
ist unschuldig also Christian Lindner
ist es nicht die Initiative gewesen das
war Bundesfinanzminister Olaf Scholz
heute Bundeskanzler der ist erstmalig
eingebracht hat vor den Bundestagswahlen
in die Koalitionsverhandlungen und sie
haben sich alle drauf geeinigt
und das Problem ist nicht dass man
Sondervermögen in bestimmten
Haushaltsnotlagen oder Krisensituationen
erdenkt sondern eigentlich dass man
keinen Plan B hat wenn einem damals
schon so viele Berater gesagt haben das
könnte schwierig werden das werfe ich
den eigentlich vor dass sie jetzt sehr
planlos sind und das Geld sammeln und
suchen müssen und trotzdem ist es
eigentlich auch eine Riesenchance weil
wenn diese Koalition jetzt dazu
gezwungen wird dann eben aus karlshrohe
sich tatsächlich mal daran zu setzen
Politik zu machen und Politik zu machen
heißt zu priorisieren und die eigenen
ideologischen Vorgärten zu stutzen und
zu überlegen okay was bin ich bereit
reinzugeben das tun sie nämlich
tatsächlich seit zwei Jahren nicht seit
zwei Jahren ist Jahrmarkt weil Krise
also darf jeder seine Wunsch Ausgaben
umsetzen und jetzt könnte man mal einen
Neustart wagen und sagen wir gehen alle
an die eigenen Töpfe ran und jeder fängt
bei sich selbst mal an und dann kommt
man vielleicht sogar zu einem
effektiveren effizienteren vielleicht
sogar günstigeren stat ohne dass man an
die Schuldenbremse ran muss die heute
auch schon flexibel ist und in der Tat
da gibt es ja viele Beispiele ein Fall
der ja jetzt ganz akut auf der Kippe
steht und wo es ja gut wäre wenn der
nicht kommen wä würde sind die
Subventionen für die shipfabriken da
gibt es noch keinen Förderbescheid da
ähm wenn die sich nicht was ausdenken
kommt das Geld nicht und da ist jetzt
die Frage ist das ein Problem weil man
dann wortbrüchig wird gegenüber den
ausländischen Investoren oder zeicht man
damit nicht dass das ein Staat ist der
auf Rechtsstaatlichkeit beruht der
Urteile akzeptiert und nicht macht ja
aber das Problem ist ja beide Standorte
Dresden und Magdeburg liegen ja in
Ostdeutschland jetzt sind natürlich die
Ostdeutschen Ministerpräsidenten dieser
beiden Länder natürlich schon auf der
Zinne die sagen mal wieder wir müssen
bezahlen ich glaube es geht um 10
Milliarden in Magdeburg und mehrere
Milliarden noch in Dresden ich glaube
ein Arbeitsplatz bei Intel in Magdeburg
wird mit 1 Million Euro subventioniert
eine Menge Geld ze ja schon das es
damals falsch war und jetzt ist die
Chance diesen Fehler zu korrigieren
unter dem Druck aber damit verlagert
sich Diskussion jetzt von der
ökonomischen oder der finanzpolitischen
gleich auf die regionale regionale bzw
föderalistische Ebene aber Herr Keller
wenn die die Eisenbahnbrücken in
nordrin-westfahen nicht saniert werden
weil jetzt die bahnmilliarden nicht
fließen dann ist Henrik wüst auf dem
Baum wenn wir endlich wenn wir nicht
irgendwann mal aufhören die Ebenen die
Gremien die politischen Repräsentanten
auch mal an einen Tisch zuzen und zu
sagen es geht jetzt hier nicht mehr um
proports und vorgen es geht um
verfassungsrechtliche Haushaltsführung
da müssen wir doch in der Lage sein in
diesem Land dahinzukommen dann muss man
sich über diese Interessen halt mal
hinwegsen es geht noch um mehr es geht
darum wohin will die Politik mal
abgesehen sogar von diesem
verfassungsrechtlichen Vorgang im
übrigen das möchte ich wirklich mir
riesen Anliegen ich habe gelesen dies
sei schon fast eine Staatskrise habe ich
gelesen das ist keine Staatskrise was
jetzt passiert ist das Funktionieren der
deutschen Demokratie das ist ein im
übers Ganze gesehen für mich ein absolut
positiver Vorgang die Opposition hat den
das
bundverfassung die potik ich darf ich zu
Ende
führen die Opposition hat ihre Rolle
gespielt das Bundes nicht eine
Demokratie ist ja eine rechtsstaatliche
in der Regel und der Rechtsstaat hat
funktioniert das geht zurück an die an
die Ampel die Ampel muss das Problem
lösen der Vorgang ist ein absolut
beispielhafter Vorgang demokr die wenn
alles funktioniert kein Problem hier hat
etwas nicht funktioniert aber die
Demokratie und der Rechtsstaat
funktionieren und sie sagen jetzt die
Leute verlieren das Vertrauen ja jetzt
sage ich was böses weil wir
Journalistinnen und Journalisten daraus
immer eine Katastrophe macht dies muss
man kritisieren was da läuft aber das
ist doch keine katastr das ist die
zweite verfassungsrechtliche Klage in
zwei Jahren für eine Bundesregierung ich
möchte gerne handwerklich sauberes
politisches Management mehr nicht die
Struktur funktioniert und Sie müssen
daraus lernen dass sie handwerklich
anständige Sachen machen aber es geht ja
nicht nur sie sagen es geht um Größeres
ich gebe ihn da recht es geht derzeit um
Größeres und es geht eben nicht nur
darum eine einzelne Chipfabrik zu zu
fördern oder wünscht dir was Projekte
aus dem ideologischen Fundus es geht ja
darum wie stehen wir wirtschaftlich in
den nächsten 10 15 Jahren da gelingt
unter uns das die Transformation zu
meistern klimaneutral zu werden und auch
da sitzt uns ja das
Bundesverfassungsgericht im im Nacken da
sitzen uns auch internationale
abbekommen im Nacken denn es ist ja so
es gibt ja auch ein
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil aus dem Jahre
21 das gesagt hat Klimaschutz müsst ihr
jetzt machen ihr müsst euch jetzt auf
den fadr begeben damit eben die
künftigen Generation auch noch so leben
können wie ihr das jetzt macht und
deshalb sind diese ganzen Maßnahmen die
aus dem KTF aus dem Klima und
transformationsfond
gefördert werden das sind ja keine
ideologischen Maßnahmen die sich die
Grünen irgendwann mal am Schreibtisch
ausgedacht haben oder auf ihrem
Bundeskongress oder was auch immer das
sind ja alles Maßnahmen die diesem Ziel
dienen a Deutschland für die Zukunft aus
aufzustellen und B eben auch
klimaneutral zu werden und irgendwie
muss man dieses Geld glaube ich jetzt
zusammenkratzen denn letztes Wort andere
Länder machen uns das machen machen das
doch vor also in den USA werden über 700
Milliarden Dollar investiert in den
klimaneutralen Umbau der Wirtschaft und
in Südkorea da 230 Milliarden zusammen
mit Samsung damit das Land zum größten
Chiphersteller wird und wir schaffen es
nicht irgendwie 60 Milliarden
aufzutreiben ganz kurz wenn sie was ist
denn was ist dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht eigentlich dann
wichtiger hat es sich da wi sprochen der
Klimaschutz für die kommenden
Generationen oder die Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse wie sie im Grundgesetz
steht weil das wird ja auch tatsächlich
die investitionshöhen was die
Wandel Klima Klimaschutz Gesetzgebung
Energiewende betrifft ja einschränken ja
das Verfassungsgericht hat sich
überhaupt nicht widersprochen das hat
zwei Normen geprüft und festgelegt und
jetzt ist es die Aufgabe der Politik mit
diesen beiden Urteilen umzugehen und für
den Auftrag den es aus dem klimaurteil
bekommen hat die mittelfrei zu machen
und das ist nicht Aufgabe des
Verfassungsgerichts sondern ist Aufgabe
der Politik und da hei das Zauberwort
prioritätenetzen gucken wie wir mit
knappen Mitteln
hinkommen und zwei Sachen dazu da gibt
es also erst sind im Klima und
transformationsform viele Maßnahmen drin
die sind nicht notwendig z.B diese
unsäglichen Strom und gaspreisbremsen
die Menschen bekommen haben die sie
nicht nötig hatten und das das be den
Bürgern die jetzt ihre Nebenkosten genau
ich habe immer gesagt man muss den armen
Leuten gezielt helfen subjektförderung
machen aber die Masse der die Regierung
braucht das Geld nicht der RWE Chef
braucht das Geld nicht und ehrlich
gesagt der
facharbeitab RWE braucht das Geld auch
nicht sondern das hätte man gezielt
machen müssen und das andere ist man
muss eben gucken welche Maßnahmen davon
sind wirklich notwendig und das dann an
anderer Stelle freischaufeln ein
Stichwort Kindergrundsicherung denkt auf
den ersten Blick jeder wow die brauchen
wir wir wollen alle den Kindern helfen
nur was die da gemacht haben ist ja viel
Geld auf dem Tisch legen was nicht bei
den bedürftigen Kindern ankommt ja Lisa
Paus wollte 12 aber sind sind
letztendlich 2 Milliarden eurommen wie
die Experten Lisa Paus letzte Woche in
der bundestagsörung vorgerechnet hab
aber ab 2025 und das hilft uns akut
jetzt auch nicht und 2 Milliarden sind
mil und nicht 60 Milliarden jetzt kann
man sagen man will 30 x 60 Milliarden
einsparen ja die preisbremsen waren 30
Milliarden den Milliarden wir kommen
jetzt so langsam das war ja die
gesamtsteuereinnahmen wahrscheinlich im
Jahr 2025 für die billion
erreicht kommen wir jetzt natürlich wir
rechnen uns jetzt vor Addition
Subtraktion noch mal die Schuldenbremse
wie sie jetzt im Grundgesetz steht die
ja nur Ausnahmen vorsieht bei einer
gesamtwirtschaftlichen Notlage was
sollen wir mit der machen soll sie weg
soll sie reformiert werden ich glaube
der
badenwürttembergische
Wirtschaftsminister von den Grünen hat
gesagt
weiterentwickeln was immer das
heißt ja was sollen wir jetzt damit
machen wie gehen wir jetzt mit diesem
Instrument um denn diese Diskussion wird
es jedes Jahr geben weil jedes Jahr
zu wenig Geld da ist sie hab mir selbst
in einem Tweet Lars Feld zitiert der
gesagt hat für all das was ich die
Politik alles einfallen lässt all die
Jahre all die Jahrzehnte ist immer zu
wenig Geld da und das ist aber genau der
Punkt der G wir können eine theoretische
Debatte über die Schuldenbremse führen
Klammer auf die Union hat bereits gesagt
sie macht nicht mit damit ist das aus
meiner Sicht eine virtuelle Debatte oder
wir führen beide Debatten gleichzeitig
und deswegen möchte ich schon eine Zahl
noch nennen 50 Milliarden Euro im
Haushalt Subvention Wirtschaftshilfen
Förderung fördermilliarden auch aus dem
Hause habbeck es waren 2019 vor der
Krise fünf und das Land ging auch nicht
unter die sind jetzt und das sind keine
coronamilliarden keine Klimafonds eine
sekundär mal und die das
Verfassungsgericht hat auch nicht gesagt
lieber Herr habbeck bitte machen Sie ein
heizungsgesetz dass die möglichst die
Menschen ab dem 1 Januar überfordert nur
weil Klimaschutz drauf steht heißt es
nicht dass die Maßnahmen die der grüne
Wirtschaftsminister machen will auf
jeden Fall die sind die die
verfassungsrechter wollen deswegen
müssen wir über Sinnhaftigkeit und
Wirksamkeit von Maßnahmen reden und dann
können wir gerne auch über die
Schuldenbremse reden über einen
konjunkturfaktor über mehr Flexibilität
für Investitionen aber wir haben auch
nicht wenig Investition haben wir gar
nicht es stimmt nicht es gibt auch
Studien die besagen dass wir pro Kopf
gar nicht schlechter sind als das was
was Joe Biden über die Jahre hinaus
macht da gibt's verschiedene Studien
diese eine Zahl die immer Schaufenster
gestellt wird ist oft nicht die
vergleichbare also insofern wenn man
ablenken will von einer Aufgabenkritik
des Bundes durch die
schuldenbremsedebatte dann bitte nein
das ist die größte Bundesregierung aller
Zeiten die hat mehr Mitarbeiter als
jeder privatwirtschaftliche Unternehmen
in Deutschland nur noch edicaa und
Siemens hat mehr Mitarbeiter als diese
Bundesregierung aber darüber red die wir
können jetzt hier Finanzpolitik
betreiben was machen wir sind sowieso
die besten Finanzpolitiker hier das ist
ganz klar ich verbeuge mich vor ihnen
aber das ist nicht der Sinn der Sinn ist
zu sehen woran hat die ganze Sache
gekrankt damit es zu dieser umwitmung
kam auch ein schöner begriff umwitmung
ich sehe so da war ein Regenbogen passt
ja auch von den Farben zu den Grünen und
man gedacht am Ende das wissen wir
kriegen wir als Kinder mit ist ein
Goldtopf und diese
Regenbogen Philosophie eine Regierung
geht nicht und wenn sie sagen diese 50
Milliarden Subventionen die sind nicht
überall nötig nein weil der Markt es
auch schafft es geht auch ums Umdenken
dass es andere Wege gibt die das was sie
möchten auch erreicht vielleicht sogar
effizienter sogar effizienter das wurde
das wurde von den Grünen erdacht ist ja
auch eine Erweckungsbewegung das finde
ich ganz toll sie hat ja eine
riesenhtorische Leistung aber ich glaube
man muss sich von dieser Ideologie lösen
aber dann alle drei und noch mal ihre
liberal
we ich werde Christian sagen sie ich
habe eine richtige Gegnerin von ihm
kennengelernt das ist toll die aber aber
weil sie sagen die Kräfte des Marktes
werden es schaffen die Schulen Bremse
ist zu einer Zeit eingeführt worden als
die Kräfte des Marktes katastrophal
versagt haben das war nämlich 2009 also
erdacht und und dann scharf gestellt
wurde sie später aber 2009 mitten in der
Finanzkrise als der Staat nämlich
Milliarden aufgenommen hat um Banken die
sich verspekuliert hatten zu stützen und
wenn man sagen will wer ist eigentlich
Schuld an der derzeitigen Situation wer
hat sich das jetzt eigentlich ausgedacht
dann muss man eigentlich Hans Eichel und
an Angela Merkel noch mal in Haftung
nehmen also die Sozialdemokraten haben
haben die Suppe mit einge ck die sie
jetzt
eigentlich die Grünen die Grünen das
muss man auch mal sagen die waren
seinerzeit gegen die Einführung dieser
Schuldenbremse weil man jetzt nämlich
merkt die Schuldenbremse die bremst
nicht nur die Verschuldung die bremst
den Staat aus und deshalb muss man da
reinin muss Stein der das mit Angela
Merkel ausgehackt hat die G aber d muss
man muss man dann muss ich leider
Wieders sprechen die Schuldenbremse
bremst den Staat nicht aus und wir
können die Debatte gerne führen aber die
Schuldenbremse muss bleiben wir können
gerne darüber reden ob die
0,35% die da als Klausel drin stehen äh
zu schwach sind äh das Institut der
deutschen Wirtschaft sagt ja auch 1,5
ist auch tragbar da können wir gerne
reden aber grundsätzlich ist es wichtig
diesen Staat diesen gefräßigen gierigen
Staat zu bändigen und ihm da diese
Leitplanken anzulegen wie das durch die
Schuldenbremse ähm geschieht und dass
wir die Banken retten mussten war extrem
ärgerlich zum Glück haben wir ja auch
eine Bankenaufsicht dann äh verschärft
nur das war damals ohne Alternative
hätten wir das nicht gemacht
hätten wir den Zusammenbruch des Systems
erhebt aber deshalb ist es ja so wichtig
den Staat zu binden und deshalb die
Schuldenbremse muss bleiben also die man
kann ja nicht sagen dass von der
Bankenkrise her alles sich erklärt das
ist ja nicht der Nukleus der Problematik
das war eine Problematik und wen wer
sagt Ihnen das ein Land das dort dicke
drin war jetzt sind wir ja gerade wieder
in so einer Sache gewesen mit der CS
also im Umgang mit Banken sind wir
unglaublich professionell das heißt wir
lassen alles zu
aber es ist auch nicht der Staat ist
nicht gefräsig gefräsig sind die die
sich des Staates bedienen in dem Satz
sie sind ja unglaublich sprachaffin habe
ich gemerkt in diesem Satz steckt eine
Verläumdung die die Leute dann gerne
mitnehmen und sag der Staat nein es sind
z.B die Grünen z.B die Sozialdemokrat
nicht nur die haben ja ich sage immer es
ist es gibt drei
verantwortungsparteien die die Dinge in
die Hand nehmen müssen in den westlichen
europäischen Demokratien das sind das
ist die liberale Familie die ist bei
ihnen klein das ist die
christdemokratische Familie und das ist
die sozialdemokratische Familie und wir
haben immer gehabt die Kommunisten links
außen und jetzt die Grünen die haben
eine
Initiativkraft die bringen ein Thema
aber das Thema ist inzwischen in
bei den
verantwortungsparteien ich behaupte das
mal der ST ist gefräig eine Zahl
sozialgabene bei
41% dieen Arbeitnehmer müssen 41%
inzwischen an die
sozial genau nicht der Staat sondern die
den Staat benutzen für das der Staat an
sich gibt's nicht an sich es ist
Struktur
ständig die Politik der Staat immer das
ist sie wissen ja was fröing meint es es
gibt ein Wachstum in Ausgaben in
staatlichen Ausgaben in Feldern wo sich
der Staat mal zurückziehen sollte und
das tut er in diesem Land weniger als in
jedem anderen Land zurü wir wir haben
schon mehrere mehrere beispielevention
Kindergrundsicherung vielleicht nein
noch mal wir haben 140 verschiedene
familienpolitische Maßnahmen und wir
haben ein Kinderarmut die ist die ist
existentiell die ist beispielha deshalb
sollte man sich aus der nein aber es ist
nein aber das ist doch gar nicht mE ein
Argument das ist das das ist ein typisch
linkes Argument mehr Geld in
ineffiziente Maßnahmen mehr nein es hat
nicht funktioniert vielleicht reden wir
mal darüber dass wir endlich das
umstellen wie wir leisten anstatt mehr
Geld in ein ineffizient ist es hat ja
nicht funktioniert wir haben 140
politische Maßnahmen und Kinderarmut und
5000 Schüler die ohne Abschluss
rausgehen aber wir haben so viele
Maßnahmen wie nie vielleicht können wir
endlich mal darüber nachdenken ob die
wirken bevor wir noch mehr Geld
reingeben aber vielleicht sollen wir
jetzt mal das ganze auf die
Regierungsebene heben das ist die Ampel
und da sagt man ja auch immer dass
Selbstkritik der erste Weg zur Besserung
ist ich weiß nicht genau wer es war aus
der FDP hat jemand gesagt wir müssten
jetzt wenn wir eben weniger Geld zur
Verfügung haben die Schuldenbremse
einhalten müssen alle mal damit sind die
drei Parteien in der Ampel gemeint auf
unsere Herzensanliegen verzichten ich
versuche mal so ein paar Herzensanliegen
hier zu tirieren die FDP verzichtet also
will die hat kein Problem die
schuldbremse abzuschaffen die Steuern zu
erhöhen dass die Wagen und
dieselprivileg zu beseitigen die Grünen
verzichten auf Grundsicherung auf die
Heizungs und Energiewende und die SPD
schafft die Rente mit 63 ab und erhöht
das Bürgergeld nicht und reduziert den
R das sind diese Herzensanliegen die ich
zitiert habe und darauf sollten wir
jetzt verzichten die Frage ist wenn man
so etwas hört wir müssen eben auf unsere
sagen die Parteien der Ampel auf unsere
Herzensanliegen verzichten
zeigt das dass Sie erkannt haben in
welcher Situation sie sind ja vermutlich
wurde das gesagt mehr in Richtung
Herzensanliegen der anderen das ist ja
immer das Problem daran m natürlich muss
die Ampel jetzt genau haben wir ja schon
gesagt die Ausgaben klar besprechen ich
glaube am Ende des Tages wird die Ampel
darüber nicht auseinandergehen weil
für alle gibt's ja keine Alternative
wenn die jetzt Neuwahlen machen fliegt
die FDP aus dem Bundestag der Kanzler
heißt nicht mehr Olaf Scholz sondern
wahrscheinlich Friedrich Merz Hendrik
wüst mal gucken wie die Debatte ausgeht
und die Grünen schmieren ja sowieso
total ab sie haben ja schon durch das
heizungsgesetz so stark gelitten das
heißt es gibt jetzt eine sehr große
Anspannung aber die Ampel wird daran
nicht scheitern auch wenn in der
Vergangenheit die Koalitionen die
gescheitert sind immer am Geld
gescheitert sind die Ampel ist ja auch
ein ganz interessantes Experiment oder
eine Erscheinung eine neue indem dort
drei Parteien miteinander diskutieren
müssen und lös finden müssen also nicht
zwei die ohnehin verwandt sind mit zwei
geht das sondern drei die ihre
Verwandtschaft jetzt langsam zu
diskutieren beginnen aber die müssen
sich zusammenfinden für Deutschland auch
was neues und diese Ampel um mal was
Positives für die zu sagen die kamen
natürlich in eine Situation hinein 16
Jahre runterdimmen der Politik wie in
einem Raum wo es immer dunkler wird
runter immer der Politik durch Merkel
dann kommt die
coronaageschichte dann kommt der Krieg
dann jetzt haben wir die Gaza Geschichte
und das ist und die Klima die
Klimaproblematik kommt ganz massiv das
ist unglaublich was die in einen neuen
Konstellation die ungeübt ist was die da
handwerklich leisten müssen gebe ich
ihnen total recht herer
und ja ungewohnterweise sie sagen es
zurecht also die Ampel muss ja jetzt
ganz viele Probleme die einfach liegen
geblieben sind anpacken ähm die große
Koalition also Angela Merkel und so die
haben ja einen Klimaschutzgesetz
beschlossen aber sie haben natürlich
keine Maßnahmen ergriffen um das
umzusetzen also das muss jetzt passieren
und noch mal zu den zu den Maßnahmen
jeder versicht verzichtet auf seine
herzenprojekte ne ich finde vieles von
dem was jetzt vorgetragen wird ist auch
wohlfeil und plakativ Beispiel
Bürgergeld ja wir sparen einfach mal am
Bürgergeld sieht als sieht ja gut aus
sind 40 Milliarden Euro also kernbürger
Geld also die Regelsätze plus plus die
Wohnkosten aber auch dazu gibt es ja ein
Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts nämlich dass
das Bürgergeld damals noch Harz 4 also
bzw dass das Existenzminimum gesichert
werden muss und genau das ist im
Bürgergeld enthalten das sind ja keine
exorbitanten Luxusgüter die dort bezahlt
werden müssen sondern da wird nach einem
sehr transparenten Verfahren
ausgerechnet was ist das Existenzminimum
und genau das wird gesichert und die
Ampel hat sich ja auch nicht auf riesige
höhung geeinigt sie hat einfach nur
gesagt die Inflation wird jetzt zeitnah
mit eingerechnet und dazu dadurch kommen
jetzt auch die großen Steigerung gar
nicht bewertet wie wichtig oder wie
unwichtig eine das Verabschieden eines
Herzens an wenn jetzt und wenn man jetzt
sagt okay bleiben wir doch noch mal beim
Bürgergeld wir könnten da sparen ja wir
könnten sparen da gibt's ja noch 10
Milliarden Euro für Verwaltung und
Eingliederungsmaßnahmen gut dann sagt
man man spart an den
Eingliederungsmaßnahmen das heißt die
Maßnahmen die Leute eigentlich
rausbringen sollen aus dem Bürger Geld
und fit machen für den Arbeitsmarkt die
sparen mal jetzt mal weg prima Idee fr
es wird eine neue Bürokratie aufgebaut
beim Bürger haben sie sich mal mit den
Fakten auseinandergesetzt es wird
plötzlich bei der Familienkasse der
Bundesagentur für Arbeit wird eine neue
Bürokratie aufgebaut damit das
Bürgergeld überhaupt ausgezahlt werden
kann so als vuer hier nicht har vi
gegeben bei aller Liebe wir müssen mehr
Beamten jetzt damit Bürgergeld
ausgezahlt wird an einer Zahl wie die
noch nie so hoch ist wie jetzt da kann
mir doch keiner mehr erzählen das ist
alles soziokulturelles existenzm aus
Karlsruhe sie verwechseln immer eine
Grundsatzurteil aus Karlsruhe zu
konkreter Politik die Ampel macht immer
mehr als Karlsruhe will sie macht's
detaillierter sie macht's leider dann
auch ausgefranzter und das ist beim
Bürgergeld genauso passiert karlsr sagt
doch nicht dass der bürgergeldgesetz
genauso aussehen muss karlsr sagt es
gibt ein soziokulturelles Existenz das
muss eingehalt werden aber dieses
bürgergeldgesetz ist mehr als das was
aus karlsruhr angelangt deswegen kann
man sich nicht immer hinter karlsruhr
verstecken daran z.B zeigt dass es
Bürgergeld so hoch ist wenn sie sich die
Sätze angucken inklusive Kosten der
Unterkunft dass so ein Haushalt mit zwei
Kindern hat 4000 € netto zur Verfügung
da muss eine Friseurin verdammt lange
für Haare schneiden und dass die
Frisuren weniger hat als eine
Bürger hat sie sie kann dann teilweise
aufstocken Sozialhilfe nehmen aber für
4000 € da muss auch ein Facharbeiter
lange arbeiten und beim Thema Bürokratie
noch die Bundesanstalt für Arbeit hat
noch genauso viele Mitarbeiter wie zur
Zeit von 5 Millionen
Arbeitslosen auch da ist beim Thema
effizen machen Thema Ampel und ihren ob
sie wackelt oder nicht zurück führen sie
wackelt nicht heißt es das heißt man
muss zusammen bleiben es gibt ja
driftige Gründe sich nicht zu trennen
und sie nicht hochgehen zu lassen aber
ist das wirklich noch möglich wenn immer
weniger zur Verfügung steht um die
eigenen Herzensanliegen dann zu bedienen
die eigene Klientel weil die
schultenbremse da steht weil gespart
werden muss weil man sich zerfetzt was
muss priorisiert werden was nicht da
würde jedem Minister etwas anderes
einfallen äh kann es nicht zu diesem
Punkt kommen dass ich die Ampel in ihrer
ganzen Konstruktion genau wegen dieser
fehlenden Finanzen überdehnt ich habe 29
bis 2013 erlebt schwarzgelb ich habe
selten so eine schlechte Stimmung erlebt
zwischen zwei Koalitionspartnern wie bei
dem damaligen Wunschbündnis schwarzgelb
dann die letzte Phase der Große
Koalition die Wahrheit ist die
Demoskopie schweißt diese Ampel zusammen
Demoskopie ist der Kit dieser dieser
Koalition Olaf Scholz müsste ja sich
selbst abschaffen denn natürlich käme
dann ein Lars klingball wenn er
plötzlich nicht mehr Bundeskanzler wäre
oder ein anderer der dann
Spitzenkandidat bei neuwahn wäre warum
warum soll ein Abgeordneter der der
koalitionsfraktion ein Interesse an der
Auflösung des Parlaments haben niemand
hat das und deswegen wird es am Ende
selbst Christian Lindner hat doch jetzt
einen Nachtragshaushalt gemacht mit dem
Aussetzen der Schuldenbremse dass er vor
einem Jahr noch auf jeden Fall
ausgeschlossen er hat gesagt das ist
verfassungswidrig das werde ich nie
machen er hat fast sein Amt damit
verknüpft und macht es jetzt doch hat
aber den Mitgliederbefragung jetzt Imen
dass aus diesem Grund die
Koalition die FP steigt aus einem
Regierungsprojekt damals war es ja noch
keins aber dann dann ist sie bei derer 2
3% Partei angelangt also das wird nicht
passieren die die Notlage ist eben nicht
nur im Haushalt so groß sondern sie ist
auch in der Ampel so groß und alle
anderen Alternativen machen diese drei
Parteien noch kleiner ganz kurz wegen
der FDP noch die krebst ja so um die 5%
rum in Wahlumfragen sie ist
möglicherweise in ihrer Existenz
gefährdet die nächste Bundestagswahl die
könnte richtig ins Auge gehen wie hart
muss denn Christian Lindner jetzt
bleiben bei dieser Finanzpolitik äh und
muss er vielleicht so hart bleiben dass
er die Koalition dann vielleicht doch
zum platzen bringt das kann ich nicht
beurteilen er muss ein guten Eindruck
machen indem er saubere Arbeit leistet
das ist ganz wichtig ob ihm die anderen
dann zustimmen oder nicht er in die
Minderheit kommt das ist das eine
solange drin ist muss er das riskieren
ich glaube schon dass sie haben gesagt
dass so eicht hin da sind sie bei 3% und
so das ist ein Problem für Deutschland
keine Liberalen das sage ich linke hier
sind ja nicht sie von der Tat das bin
ich ich bin ich bin ich bin ein
gewerksschaftsgründer ein jung Sozialist
ein Parteipräsident ein
Parlamentarier ein Genosse
ja ich s nicht D jetzt
no noch etwas und sie was ich habe
Schriftsätze gelernt im Blei ich habe
einmal gearbeitet ich bin Handwerker
sehe was fehlt in der Politik in
Deutschland die werden gar nicht mehr
angesprochen die werden schon versorgt
haben sie recht mit dem Bürgergeld das
auch in Ordnung aber richtig als Kultur
an angenommen ich will jetzt sie haben
von Korea geredet und von weiß der
Teufel wo ich könnte sagen
Wilders nicht das haben die Leute auch
die Schnauze voll das kommt dann raus
und hier geht es drum noch Z Jahre ich
bin bei ihrem Thema gute Arbeit zu
leisten das kann man das können die das
sind intelligente Leute ich würde wissen
wenn ich wenn ich so über die Grünen
rede da sage ich auch mal was ganz
versönlich eigentlich für mich ist mein
Freund Otto schili ein ein ein Beispiel
der ging von den der ging zu den
Sozialdemokraten ein habck gehört zu den
Sozialdemokraten sogar eine der rözte
mir das sind Leute die zu den
verantwortungsparteien müssen weil die
können was sie können letztlich was aber
wenn sie
Vorsitz wenn Sie vorsitzend wenn Sie
Vorsitzender sind der Grünen sind sie ja
nicht frei sie müssen sich daran
gewöhnen dass die Grünen eventuell auch
eine verantwortungspartei sind oder ne
ist das nicht wir
n eine
Erweckungsbewegung haben sie ja
vollkommen Recht die die müssen sind
zusammengespeist aber es ist natürlich
überhaupt keine Liebesheirat mehr
sondern war von Anfang an ja auch nicht
aber es ist auch keine zukunftskoalition
sondern es ist ein Zweckbündnis man
rettet sich bis umum Tag der Scheidung
das Problem daran ist und auch wie die
nächsten zwei Jahre werden was bedeutet
das mit Blick auf die AFD eine Koalition
die jetzt noch zwei Jahre maximale
Unzufriedenheit schürt durch
Streitereien und durch schlechte Politik
wird natürlich das AFD Problem noch mal
größer machen wenn diese Menage dann in
zwei Jahren zu Ende sein könnte selbst
wenn die Grünen da mit ein blauen Auge
oder ein grünen Auge davon kommen es
nützt ihn ja nichts wenn sie danach in
die Opposition müssen dann hätten sie
auch nicht mehr die mögkeit Politik zu
gestalten welche Rolle spielen sie da
jetzt wie müssen sie taktisch müssen Sie
strategisch vorgehen um grüne Politik ja
Fortsetzung fortzusetzen fortsetzen zu
können keine keine der drei
ampelparteien hat was davon wenn sie in
die Opposition geht auch das ist ein
Grund zusammen zu bleiben und möglichst
wieder eine Mehrheit zu kriegen bei der
nächsten Wahl und was die Grünen ja
machen ist dass sie sich ganz stark von
diesem Image der Erweckungsbewegung
verabschiedet haben und
selbst der Klima und transformationsfond
hab hat sich da neulich versprochen und
hat gesagt Wirtschafts
wirtschaftsförderungs und
transformationsfond also so hättet er es
wahrscheinlich von Anfang an am liebsten
genannt also dass ich sehr klar darauf
setzen zu sagen wir machen das hier
nicht für uns oder für unsere grüne
Basis sondern wir machen das für dieses
Land also die treten unglaublich
staatstragend auf waren schon in der
Vergangenheit unglaublich pragmatisch
haben ja Kompromisse gemacht die man den
Grünen nie zugetraut hätte z.B in der in
der Asyl und Einwanderungspolitik also
Außenlage an den Grenzen also früher wä
die grüne Basis im Quadrat gesprungen
und jetzt sagt sie na ja ist nicht schön
mach mal aber mit und das das diesen
Kurs f die Grünen eigentlich schon das
das die ganze Zeit die krcks ist es wird
ihn überhaupt nicht also keiner scheint
zu bemerken alle sagen nur ach diese
verbotspartei ach da müssen wir uns mal
von alten docmen verabschieden was die
grün die ganze Zeit längst machen also
was sie machen Frau le das macht die FDP
ja auch und deswegen hat sie vier Land
daswahlen verloren weil sie natürlich
auch
mus im N auf dieen die soel machen mus
kohilered die FDP hat es natürlich auch
gemacht drei Sondervermögen
Schuldenbremse ausgesetzt das waren
alles Wahlkampfversprechen die FP ger
die verkaufen
nicht Herr Lindner hätte doch jetzt die
Gelegenheit gehabt sich als Staatsmann
zu präsentieren der hätte sagen können
ich handle jetzt im Interesse des Landes
ich sehe die Verunsicherung Liebe
Wirtschaft ihr wartet auf eure EUR
Subvention Liebe Handwerker ihr rechnet
mit den energiepreisbremsen ich mache es
möglich ich Christian lind als
Staatsmann Nachen sieh sieht so aus als
hätte man ihm sein rotes Auto
weggenommen als er heute in der
Press auch gem heizungsgesetz sich auch
hinstellen K der Ampel so weitergt und
möglicherweise noch weniger Geld zur
Verfügung steht und die
Verteilungskämpfe noch härter werden
dann sagen ja manche das sein ein
Konjunkturprogramm für die AFD ist ja
gerade schon angesprochen worden ist
eine reelle Gefahr ja die Gefahr steht
sehr zumal ja viele Wähler auch sich der
AFD zuwenden in Unkenntnis dessen was
die Ampel macht und in Unkenntnis dessen
was die AFD auf dem Programm hat sondern
nur als Protestwahl und Wut
dagegen und dieses wird sehr zunehmen
umso wichtiger ist dass die Ampel
Prioritäten setzt und sich klar erklärt
es darf auf keinen Fall das Gefühl
aufkommen hier wird jetzt zwei Jahre
gestritten geschachert und Gesetze
durchgestochen wie das heizungsgesetz wo
ja bis heute alle Parteien behaupten der
andere war's ähäh
sowas darf natürlich nicht sein das
fördert natürlich total die Politik
Unzufriedenheit aber wissen Sie es gibt
das dieses wählen der AFD hat nicht nur
unmittelbar zu tun mit dem was die
Regierung macht sondern mit dem wie wir
die Dinge auch darstellen drum habe ich
gesagt ich ich finde es funktioniert und
zu vermitteln als Journalistinnen und
Journalisten zu vermitteln in solchen
Sendungen auch zu vermitt dass dieser
Streit eigentlich ein funktionieren der
Sache ist dass die Demokratie eigentlich
die Ordnung der Unordnung ist ein eine
eine reife Demokratie die die machen
aber wirklich schwer da jetzt ich mach
ihen nicht schwer weil bei uns
funktioniert ja aber hören sich mal
aufständig die Schweiz mit Deutschland
zu vergleichen es ist wirklich
unterschiedliches politisches System
sozialisier Mentalität nein warum nein
es funktioniert sie üben sein ich kann
mit ihnen gut da streiten machen wir das
mal auf dem Boot ich sage Ihnen sie üben
jetzt seit
dreationti voreren sie keine genau und
ich hte und die Deutschen hätten einfach
gerne in den in einer multiplen
Krisenzeit eine funktionierende
Regierung mehr nicht gar nicht wir
müssen Sie nicht schlecht machen wir
sind gleich wir müssen sie kritisieren
aber sie nicht schlecht machen wir sind
gleich am Ende der Sendung würde ich
gerne eine Frage stellen die ich schon
häufiger in dieser Sendung gestellt habe
aus unterschiedlichem Anlass wenn es um
die Innenpolitik gibt was macht
eigentlich gerade der Bundeskanzler
haben sie da Information Zuversicht
ausstrahl er soll ja angeblich nächste
Woche eine Rede im Bundestag halten
wollen
Stichwort er soll ja auch er muss ja
auch führen in dieser Situation die wir
hier zum Teil beklagen er sagt er
respektiert das Urteil des
Verfassungsgerichts doch eine
erstaunliche Aussage für ein Kanzler
angeblich trifft er sich ja gerade oder
Brie da gerade die
ministerpräsidentinnen und bringt sie
auf den Stand wie es jetzt weitergeht
und ansonsten glaube ich muss er ganz
viel reden und zwischen den Parteien
vermitteln natürich recht mit Ihrer
Frage das ist ja auch ein Problem der
Ampel und manche Sachen die sie auch
richtig gemacht haben kommen so schlecht
weg weil sie schlecht kommuniziert
worden sind und da ist kann man also
sagen das Urteil ist auch in der Weise
eine Chance für die Ampel ihre
Kommunikation noch mal auf neue Beine zu
stellen und den Kanzler zu animieren zu
das müsste der Bundeskanzler mitbekommen
dass es auch aber der Kanzler redet ja
eiglich sehr viel er sagt nur wenig er
gibt so viele Interviews wie Angela
Merkel in zwei Legislaturen nicht der
ist eigentlich sehr präsent er sagt nur
nichts ich weiß nicht was er jetzt nach
diesem wirklich will will er das was wir
hier besprechen oder gar nichts davon
ich wüsste es einfach mal gerne und
insofern wahrscheinlich wieder eine
Regierungserklärung und dann wieder ganz
viel Zuversicht alleeden das Reden das
landschrecht und ich weiß nicht ob
irgendwann das noch hilft wenn man
ständig irgendwie sagt ihr da draußen
habt's nicht verstanden es läuft doch
alles gut dann haben wir ihm jetzt ein
paar Anregungen gegeben was man
möglicherweise tun kann wir beobachten
das weiter auch dieses Thema bleibt uns
erhalten ich bedanke mich bei Anti
höhning bei Anna le bei Michael Bröker
und bei Frank Meer Liebe Zuschauerin
liebe Zuschauer noch das ganze
Wochenende ist phöniix live dabei bei
der bundesdelegierten Konferenz der
bündnisgrün in Karlsruhe da soll es ja
durchaus Fidel zugehen da ist auch noch
einiges im Busch es gibt ja schon
Informationen dass die Parteiführung
bitter bereut den Parteitag vier lange
Tage zu zelebrieren aber dazu ist es zu
spät phöniix ist wie gesagt live dabei
wir haben Kondition sind sie auch dabei
und bleiben Sie bei
[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta slomker guten Abend in
der Kürze liegt die Würze dachte sich
wohl Christian Lindner sprach schmal
lippig drei Sätze in die Kameras und
verschwand wieder die Würze lag dann vor
allem in dem was er wörtlich nicht sagte
aber sinngemäß mitteilte die
Schuldenbremse wird für
2023 auch nachträglich ausgesetzt mit
einem sogenannten Nachtragshaushalt der
wie das Wort schon sagt nachträglich
Änderungen vornimmt in diesem Fall soll
der Haushalt für das ablaufende Jahr
nachträglich gerichtsfest gemacht werden
man wird also im Nachhinein eine
außergewöhnliche Notlage erklären diese
Notlösung mit der Notlage war zu
erwarten Lindner wollte das ursprünglich
nicht aber was anderes blieb ihm jetzt
wohl gar nicht mehr übrig aus Berlin
Frank
buchwalt in diesem Haus wagt der
Minister heute einen Befreiungsschlag
ein Nachtragshaushalt soll es richten
erstmal für